GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. SENATE
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION WILL COME TO ORDER.
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
JOINING US TODAY. WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A QUORUM, SO
WE'LL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE,
WE HAVE, THREE, SIX, EIGHT BILLS
ON CONSENT. WE'LL TAKE THEM UP
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM, FIRST
BILL UP IS FILED. ITEM NUMBER
TWO. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1868
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. SHE
IS HERE. THANK YOU FOR BEING ON
TIME AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I
ACCEPT THE SUGGESTED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, WHICH MERELY ADD
COAUTHORS TO THE BILL. I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED WIDE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS HAD NO, NO VOTES SO FAR.
AB SIX 1868 SEEKS TO HELP LOW
INCOME HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
HOME OWNERSHIP CAN AFFORD, THE
STABILITY THE BUILDING OF
EQUITY, AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE POLICIES ACROSS THE STATE
THAT ARE THAT AS AS INTENTIONAL,
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. AB 1868 ADDRESSES
THE WIDE VARIANCE BETWEEN
JURISDICTIONS ABOUT HOW THEY
ASSESS THE VALUE OF AFFORDABLE
HOMES SOLD TO AND OCCUPIED BY
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN LOW TO NO
INTEREST MORTGAGE PROGRAMS.
BASICALLY, WHAT HAPPENS IS IN
MANY COMMUNITIES WHEN THEY'RE
ASSESSING THESE RATES, THEY LOOK
AT THE OWNER, THE PERSON WHO'S
GOING TO BE LIVING IN THE HOME,
THAT LOW INCOME PERSON. BUT SOME
JURISDICTIONS ARE LOOKING AT THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE HELPING TO
BUILD THE HOME, WHICH CAN BE
CITIES, THEY CAN BE NONPROFITS,
WHICH OF COURSE, ARE MUCH HIGHER
RESOURCED, AND THEY'RE SETTING
THEIR RATES BASED ON THAT. THIS
CAN CREATE A BARRIER TO
PRODUCING THESE HOMES IN SOME
COMMUNITIES, THEREBY ROBBING LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES OF THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE ONE OF THESE UNITS. SO
THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS THAT
DISPARITY AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT THE PEOPLE WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT, WHICH IS
THE ULTIMATE OWNER OF THE HOME.
BEING THE LOW INCOME RESIDENT.
OUR SPONSOR OF THE BILL IS
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION, WHO ARE
NOW NEUTRAL ON THE BILL. THERE
IS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION AND WITH
THAT TESTIFYING WITH ME HERE
TODAY IS SOMEONE FROM HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY, DEBBIE ARAKKAL,
WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
BEFORE WE GO TO YOUR WITNESS,
DEBBIE, WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. SO, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE MEMBERS. SENATORS
GLAZER HERE. GLAZER. PRESENT.
DOLLY. DOLLY. PRESENT. ASHBY
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE. PRESENT
DODD. PADILLA. SOMEWHERE IN THE
ROOM. PADILLA PRESENT. SKINNER.
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY, A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR LEAD WITNESS.
DEBBIE, TELL ME YOUR LAST NAME
AGAIN. GREAT. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CARE
GLAZER. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS
DEBBIE ORACLE AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA. AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE VIEWS OF
OUR HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
AFFILIATES SERVING 42 COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE ARE
PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 1868 AT
HABITATS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE BUILT THOUSANDS OF HOMES
AND ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING HUNDREDS MORE. THESE
ARE ENTRY LEVEL DEED RESTRICTED
HOMES TO OAN HABITAT. HOME
BUYERS EARN BETWEEN 30 AND 80%
AREA MEDIAN INCOME, AND WE ARE
ALSO PROUD TO SHARE THAT 8,083%
OF OUR HABITAT HOMEOWNERS ARE
BLACK, INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. HABITAT IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED IN THIS HOME
OWNERSHIP SPACE. AS A BUILDER,
DEVELOPER, MORTGAGE LENDER, AND
COMMUNITY BUILDER, WE'VE HAD
SITUATIONS WHEN THE PROPERTY
TAXES WERE ASSESSED WITH MINIMAL
CONSIDERATION TO THE
AFFORDABILITY AND DEED
RESTRICTIONS, WHICH RESULTS IN
OVER ASSESSED VALUES WITH MUCH
HIGHER PROPERTY TAXES THAN
ESTIMATED, RATHER THAN THE
PROPORTION TO THE FIRST
MORTGAGE. THIS REQUIRES A
MORTGAGE REDUCTION IN ORDER TO
KEEP THE HOME BUYERS MONTHLY
PAYMENTS AFFORDABLE, SO THIS
BURDENS HABITAT FOR HUMANITY OR
OTHER NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS,
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING OUR BUDGETS
AND LEAVING LESS FUNDING TO
BUILD MORE HOMES. THIS BILL
CODIFIES A BEST PRACTICE
ADMINISTERED BY MANY COUNTIES
ALREADY, AND SUPPORTS THE
ASSESSOR'S COMMITMENT TO
CONSISTENT AND UNIFORM
APPROACHES TO ASSESSING DEED
RESTRICTED PROPERTIES. AS A 500
1C3 NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOME
BUILDER AND LENDER WERE HONORED
TO SPONSOR AB 1868 AND JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAURA FRIEDMAN
TO ACHIEVE EQUITABLE PROPERTY
TAXATION ON AFFORDABLE OWNER
OCCUPIED HOMES. I AM GRATEFUL TO
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MISS ORACLE, FOR BEING HERE.
ANYONE ELSE WANT TO GIVE A ME
TOO IN FAVOR OF THIS MEASURE?
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING ACTION COALITION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM? ALL
RIGHT, WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SEEING NO
ONE COMING FORWARD, WE'LL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
RECOGNIZE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
BRADFORD IN JUST A MOMENT.
SENATOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, JUST I WOULD REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. AND I THANK EVERYONE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. GREAT. HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK IN THIS AREA. AND
THANK YOU TO HABITAT FOR DECADES
AND DECADES OF GREAT SERVICE TO
OUR LOWER INCOME COMMUNITY AND
HELPING THEM GET HOMEOWNERSHIP.
SO THANK YOU, I'M GOING TO
RECOGNIZE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
BRADFORD. THIS WOULD BE DO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR GLASER. GLASER. AYE
DOLLY. POLLEY. AYE. ASHBY.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. DODD.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. SKINNER
FORTIES0. WE'LL PUT THAT MATTER
ON. CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBERS, WHY DON'T WE TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR? RESPECT
ALL THE FOLKS THAT ARE HERE.
SENATOR BRADFORD HAS MOVED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS IS,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1828, 1983, 2197,
26, 89, 29, 79, 32, 87, 32, 88
AND 32, 89. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOTION IS ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATORS
GLAZER AYE. GLAZER AYE. DOLLY.
DOLLY AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. DODD PADILLA.
PADILLA AYE. SKINNER 40 ZERO.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT MATTER
ON. CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO OUR LAST ITEM
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TEN, THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER TEN, H.R. 15 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NGUYEN. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THIS MORNING. AND THE
FLOOR IS YOURS WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY, GOOD MORNING, SENATORS.
TODAY I'M PRESENTING HJR 15,
WHICH URGES CONGRESS TO REVISIT
THE MISGUIDED DECISION TO CAP
STATE AND LOCAL INCOME TAXES AT
10,000 FOR BOTH INDIVIDUALS AND
MARRIED COUPLES. THE SALT
DEDUCTION HAS BEEN A FEATURE OF
THE FEDERAL TAX CODE THAT DATES
BACK TO THE VERY FIRST INCOME
TAX THAT WAS IMPOSED DURING THE
CIVIL WAR. THE LOGIC THEN, WHICH
STILL APPLIES TODAY, IS THAT TAX
PAYMENTS TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT OPTIONAL. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT BE
TAXING, INCOME THAT'S ALREADY
SPOKEN FOR. AND WHICH PEOPLE
HAVE NO CONTROL OVER. DOING SO
WOULD CONSTITUTE A TAX UPON
ATTACKS. BY RECOGNIZING THIS
SIMPLE FACT, THE SALT DEDUCTION
REFLECTS A KEY PRINCIPLE OF
FEDERALISM AND NONINTERFERENCE
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
STATE AND LOCAL AFFAIRS. ONLY
RECENTLY, IN 2017, DID THIS
CONSENSUS GIVE WAY. WHEN AN TCJA
WAS PASSED BY CONGRESS. SOME IN
DC WERE NOT SHY ABOUT USING THE
SALT DEDUCTION AS A TOOL TO PUT
THEIR FINGER ON THE SCALE AND
PUNISH HIGH TAX STATES. THIS WAS
NOT ABOUT THOUGHTFUL TAX POLICY,
AS EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT
MARRIED COUPLES AND INDIVIDUAL
FILERS ARE ALLOWED THE SAME
DEDUCTION AMOUNT AFTER TCJA WENT
INTO EFFECT, WE HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
PEOPLE THAT HAD PREVIOUSLY
RECEIVED REFUNDS ON THEIR
FEDERAL TAXES WERE NOW SURPRISED
THAT THEY OWED MONEY TO THE IRS,
EVEN THOUGH THEIR INCOMES STAYED
THE SAME. OVERWHELMINGLY, I
HEARD FROM MARRIED COUPLES THAT
THEY WERE RIGHTFULLY OFFENDED,
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER
OFF TO FILE SEPARATELY. AGRX 15
URGES CONGRESS TO FIX THIS
PENALTY ON MARRIED COUPLES AND
LIFT THE SALT DEDUCTION
CONSISTENT WITH HOW IT IS
OPERATED FOR DECADES PRIOR TO
THE TCJA VÀ, WITH ME TODAY IS
VANESSA CHAVEZ. CHAVEZ FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WE'LL GO TO YOUR LEAD
WITNESS. WELCOME, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, VANESSA CHAVEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND SUPPORT OF RJR 15.
THIS MEASURE CALLS ON CONGRESS
AND STRESSES THE URGENCY OF
REPEALING THE SALT CAP, WHICH
WAS ENACTED UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. THE CHANGE
PENALIZED HIGH COST STATES SUCH
AS CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK AND
NEW JERSEY, BY LIMITING THE
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES THAT A
TAXPAYER IS ABLE TO DEDUCT. FOR
EXAMPLE, IN SAN FRANCISCO, THE
MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME, AS
REPORTED BY THE U.S. CENSUS
BUREAU, STATES THAT IT IS
ROUGHLY $136,000 AS COMPARED TO
THE NATIONAL FIGURE, WHICH IS
HALF OF THAT AMOUNT COMING IN AT
ROUGHLY $74,000. THE SALT
DEDUCTION INCLUDES PROPERTY
INCOME AND SALES TAX TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC, A TAXPAYER WHO
ITEMIZES CAN DEDUCT PROPERTY
TAXES, BUT THE TAXPAYER NEEDS TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN DEDUCTING INCOME
AND SALES TAXES. TAXPAYERS OF
STATES WITH HIGH INCOME TAXES
TYPICALLY OPT TO DEDUCT THEIR
STATE AND LOCAL INCOME TAXES,
WHILE TAXPAYERS OF STATES WITH
HIGH SALES TAX TYPICALLY DEDUCT
THEIR SALES TAXES. GENERALLY,
TAXPAYERS DEDUCT PROPERTY AND
INCOME TAXES USING THE SALT
DEDUCTION. ONE OF THE MORE
NOTABLE, IF NOT MOST DAMAGING,
PROVISIONS IN THE TAX CUTS AND
JOBS ACT WAS THE LIMITATION OF
THE STATE AND LOCAL TAXES FOR
TAXPAYERS WHO FILE JOINTLY, AS
THE LIMITATION IS CAPPED AT
$10,000, MEANING THAT A TAXPAYER
WHO FILES SINGLE HAS THE SAME
LIMIT AS TWO TAXPAYERS WHO FILE
TOGETHER. THIS CHANGE HAS LED TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY PENALIZING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. AS A
RESULT, WE HAVE MANY FAMILIES
WHO ARE ALREADY DEALING WITH THE
MANY HARDSHIPS OF THESE CHANGES,
AND HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE INCURRING THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING, WHICH INCLUDES
INCREASED INSURANCE COSTS AND
HIGH INTEREST RATES, JUST TO
NAME A FEW. THE SALT CAP CREATES
A BURDEN FOR STATES FAMILIES,
AND REFORM IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THE RESIDENTS OF THE
STATE ARE ABLE TO MEET THE BASIC
NEEDS OF THEIR FAMILIES. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU, MISS CHAVEZ.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON AS A
ME TOO. IN FAVOR OF THIS
MEASURE, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE, WE'LL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE. WE'LL
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA. I THINK THAT, THERE'S MANY
THAT WISH YOU WELL AND US WELL
AND, MAKING THESE CHANGES. AND
WITH THAT, I THINK I HEARD A
MOTION FROM SENATOR PADILLA
SENATOR DAHLE WITH SENATOR DOLLY
. SENATOR DOLLY. DOLLY,
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. YEAH ALL
RIGHT. BIPARTISAN. THIS WOULD,
THIS BE THAT THE MATTER BE
ADOPTED? AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE Þ.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS 68 COAUTHORS. SO WE ALL LIKE
IT. AND SENATOR DOLLY, WHICH IS
A CHERRY ON TOP. ALL RIGHT. ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE, DOLLY.
DOLLY. AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE. DODD. AYE. DODD.
AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA AYE.
SKINNER FIVE ZERO. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THAT BILL
ON. CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS WHO
WERE HERE ON TIME FOR COMPLETING
OUR AGENDA TODAY. AND WE'LL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. AND WE WILL, OPEN THE
ROLL ON, ON, ON ITEMS THAT WE'VE
DEALT WITH SO THAT THE NEWER,
NEWLY ARRIVED MEMBERS CAN VOTE
AND WE ASK THOSE THAT ARE NOT
HERE TO PLEASE COME ON DOWN SO
WE CAN HAVE YOUR VOTE BE
RECORDED. SO LET US BEGIN WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, THE
SECRETARY WOULD OPEN THE ROLL
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR MOTION
IS ADOPTED. CONSENT CALENDAR
WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS ASHBY DODD
AYE. DODD AYE. SKINNER 520. PUT
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
NEXT TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN'S BILL. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1868. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL MOTION IS DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR ASHBY. DODD. AYE. DODD.
AYE. SKINNER. VIÆT ZERO. ALL
RIGHT. SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
SHORT RECESS AS WE WAIT FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ARRIVE.
OUT OF RECESS. THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL FIRST
BEGIN WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR MOTION
IS ADOPTED. CONSENT CALENDAR
WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE. SENATOR ASHBY.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. 6 TO 0.
I'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1868 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
5 TO 0 WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR. ASHBY.
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. 6 TO 0.
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND FINALLY, FILE ITEM TEN, H.R.
15 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. MOTION IS
ADOPTED AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 520 WITH CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR ASHBY. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE 6 TO 0. PUT THAT ON. CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND WE'LL GO
BACK TO RECESS. WAITING FOR OUR
FINAL MEMBER TO JOIN US.
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION. BACK TO ORDER SO WE
CAN CLOSE THE ROLL ON THE
PENDING VOTES, ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE ROLL WITH A 6 TO 0 VOTE ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S 1868.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLL ON
A 6 TO 0 VOTE. AND AS H.R. 15 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN, WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLL WITH A 6
TO 0 VOTE. THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING. THANK YOU TO THE
STAFF FOR ALL YOUR GREAT WORK
AND FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE WHO HAVE COME TO JOIN
US THIS MORNING. WITH THAT, THE
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.